لحاله الغموض
التي لا شك وانها مربكه في الحسابات
الاسرائيليه كما استمعنا من قبل للياس
كرام نعود اليه مره اخرى هنالك حاله ارباك
من تاخر الرد الفلسطيني ومع مرور الوقت
هذا الايرباك ربما لا يقل باي درجه من
الدرجات
نعم لكن دعوني اشير الى هذا المشهد ربما
الذي جاء قبل قليل هنا في مفترق زكيم حيث
شاهدنا قبل نحو نصف ساعه دخول لعده حافلات
اسرائيليه الى تلك المنطقه ونحن نعلم بان
هنالك موقع عسكري كبير للجيش الاسرائيلي
في منطقه زكي ما يعرف بقاعده زكيم وقبل
الدقائق معدوده خرجت من هذا الموقع نحو
خمس حافلات محمله بالجنود الاسرائيليين
وكانه يبدو بانها عمليه اجلاء للجنود
الاسرائيليين في تلك القاعده العسكريه اذا
هذا الخبر العاجل الذي نريده للتو حافلات
اسرائيليه محمله بالجنود الاسرائيليين
تخلي كما يبدو موقع زكيم او قاعده زكيم
العسكريه نحن لا نتحدث عن جنود مقاتلين
كما يبدو كما استطيع ان اشاهد في داخل
الحافلات تواجدت على الاغلب مجندات
الجيش الاسرائيلي وليس جنود من الوحدات
القتاليه لكن واضح بان عمليه الاجلاء هذه
تمت على عجل وبسرعه ذلك ان قاعده زكيم
العسكريه وهذا الموقع هو موقع قريب جدا من
السياج الامني مع قطاع غزه وهو عرضه
للاستهداف في كل المواجهات التي خاضتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
اذا نعود الى هذا الخبر العاجل وطبعا غير
المتوقع والمفاجئ حقيقه بان تقوم يقوم
الجيش الاسرائيلي بعمليه اجلاء واسعه على
هذا النحو لجنود اسرائيليين من هذه
القاعده قبل حتى ان تطلق المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ولو قذيفه هاون واحده او حتى
رصاصه واحده نتحدث عن خمس حافلات
اسرائيليه بمعنى اننا نستطيع ان نقدر بان
عدد الجنود او المج
اللواتي تم اخلاقهم من هذه القاعده ربما
يصل الى نحو 200 مجنده اسرائيليه في عمليه
انا على الاقل لم اشهدها من قبل وفي
التوقيت المبكر وقبل حتى على الاغلب نعم
ما استطيع ان اراه او ما استطعت ان ارصده
في داخل الحافلات الاسرائيليه كان معظمهم
من المجندات وهم عمليا يقومون بعمليات رصد
ومتابعه في غرف عمليات خاصه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في تلك المنطقه تلك الغرف التي
ترصد التحركات القريبه من السياج الامني
لا يمكن تفسير خروج هذه الحافلات من هذه
المنطقه تحديدا دون التاكيد على انها
عمليه اجلاء للمجندات وللبعض الجنود ربما
الذين يقومون بعمليات او بمهام وظيفيه
وغير قتاليه نحن لا نتحدث عن خروج وحدات
قتاليه او جنود مقات لكن طبيعه الحال هذه
العمليه عمليه الاجلاء الكبيره
نشير هنا انها تاتي في وقت تتحدث فيه ايضا
بلديه ازديروت القريبه منا عن انها تستعد
لاجلاء اربعه الاف وخمسمائه من
الاسرائيليين سكان مدينه ازديروت اعتبارا
من يوم الغد وهي تقوم بالحجوزات اللازمه
لهم في فنادق وفي دور ضيافه بعيدا عن خط
المواجهه وهذا يدلل على ان اسرائيل تاخذ
بالحسبان انها ربما تكون مقبله على ايام
عصيبه على ايام من المواجهه مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي كان
اعلن صباح هذا اليوم عن تفعيل منظومه ما
يعرف بهب النسيم وهي المنظومه التي تقوم
من خلالها الجبهه الداخليه بتقديم العون
والمساعده على اجلاء الاسرائيليين من
المناطق المستهدفه تحديدا تلك المناطق
القريبه من
الحدود وواضح بان الجبهه الداخليه تبذل
مولودا في هذا لا يوجد
هل هناك اجلاء لمدنيين من مستوطنات غلاف
غزه
لم يعلن لم يعلن عن ذلك بشكل رسمي حتى
الان لكن بلديه
وبلدات اسرائيليه اخرى قريبه من الحدود
تستعد لتنظيم او لعمليه منظمه في اجلاء
الاسرائيليين ووسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليات
تؤكد ايضا بان بلديه بالفعل تستعد لاجلائي
اربعه الاف وخمسمائه من السكان
الاسرائيليين من المدينه التي يصل تعدادها
الى نحو 33 الف اسرائيلي ومن الواضح بان
الكثير من الاسرائيليين ربما يكونوا
غادروا بواسطه سياراتهم الخاصه البلدات
القريبه من خط المواجهه منذ ساعه مبكره من
صباح هذا اليوم لكن لانهم يقومون ذلك بشكل
فردي لا يمكن في هذه الساعه حصر اعدادهم
وتحديد الاعداد بالفعل التي غادرت المكان
لكن نحن نقف في هذا المكان القريب من شمال
قطاع غزه في مفترق زكيم والكثير من
الاسرائيليين يصطدمون بهذا الحاجز العسكري
يقولون لنا بانهم متوجهون الى بلدات في
غلاف غزه مثل الازديروت وساعد وغيرها من
المناطق من اجل اجلاء اقارب واصدقائه لهم
الكثير منهم توقفوا وقالوا لنا ذلك وهذا
ربما يكون مؤشر بالفعل على ان هنالك جهود
فرديه لدى الاسرائيليين او مبادرات فرديه
لدى الاسرائيليين بالتعجل وبسرعه اجلاء
هذه المواقع وهذه البلدات القريبه من خط
المواجهه مخافه ان تكون عرضه
لاستهدافات من جانب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لكن اللافت كما اشرت وغير
المسبوق ربما في اي مواجهه سابقه نحن لم
نرى بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يسارع الى اجلاء
جنوده من قواعد عسكريه قبل حتى ان تطلق
المقاومه رصاصه واحده او قذيفه واحده
استطعت ان ارصد قبل دقائق معدوده نحو خمس
حافلات اسرائيليه كانت تقل اعدادا كبيره
من المجندات تحديدا من المجندات
الاسرائيليات كما يبدو بان هذه الحافلات
اقلتهم من قاعده زكيم العسكريه هذه
القاعده تتعرض دائما
لوابل من قذائف الهاون ومن الاستهدافات من
جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه ذلك انها مكشوفه
وذلك انها ايضا قريبه جدا من
الشاطئ وقريبه جدا ايضا من السياج الامني
مع قطاع غزه يعني الحديث الان عن نحو 200
مجنده اسرائيليه كما يبدو تم اجلائه
اجلائهن من هذه القاعده العسكريه تحسبا
لاي تدهور امني يشير هنا ايضا الى انه
بالعاده عندما تتوتر الاوضاع الامنيه بعد
عمليه اغتيال او عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يتوارى عن الانظار يختفي
يختبئ في التحصينات العسكريه وفي داخل
القواعد العسكريه المحصنه ويمتنع
اداره الدوريات المؤلله التي عاده ما تجوب
الحدود في عمليات التمشيط والرص للتحركات
على طرفي السياج الامني وذلك مخافه ان
يتحول او تتحول هذه الدوريات الى اهداف
سهله بالنسبه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه التي
تستطيع بسهوله ان توجه صواريخ الكورنيت
باتجاه هذه الاليات واصابتها اصابات
مباشره وهذا ايضا ما يفسر الاغلاق الذي
تقوم به الشرطه العسكريه لمحاور عده هنا
في منطقه غلاف غزه كهذا المفترق وهذا
الشارع الرئيسي المغلق منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى ذلك ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يخشى من
ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ربما تستهدف
السيارات الاسرائيليه
بواسطه صواريخ الكورنيت الموجهه على هذه
المحاور الرئيسيه والمكشوفه حقيقه على
الحدود مع قطاعي غزه والمقاومه الف كانت
اظهرت في الماضي عبر التسجيلات فيديو كيف
انها تستطيع ان ترقب وترصد وتصور بعدسات
الكاميرا كل التحركات على الحدود تحديدا
في مواقع التجمع الدبابات والمواقع
المشرفه والمطله على قطاع غزه من بينها
ايضا رسم مسؤولين عسكريين
ووزراء في الحكومه الاسرائيليه كانوا
ياتون الى تلك المنطقه في عمليات تفقد حتى
في ايام لم تكن تشهد فيها المنطقه مواجهه
وبالتالي اسرائيل تاخذ بعين الاعتبار بان
المقاومه على درجه عاليه من الجهوزيه على
درجه عاليه من الترقب والاستعداد والرصد
ولديها تلك الامكانيات القادره على تسديد
الضربات الموجعه
للاليات والجنود الاسرائيليين على الحدود
وفي داخل القواعد العسكريه نتحدث عن تلك
القريبه جدا من داخل قريبه جدا من السياج
الامني ملاحظه اخرى هي ان سماء المنطقه
هنا تك لا تخلو من المسيرات التي تجوب
سماء المنطقه منذ ساعات منذ ساعات عديده
وواضح بان هذه المسيرات تحاول ان ترصد اي
محاوله من الطرف الفلسطيني لاطلاق او
تحضيري المنصات الصاروخيه لاطلاقها باتجاه
البلدات الاسرائيليه وهي تبث بطبيعه الحال
صورا مباشره الى قياده العمليات والى مقر
وزاره الدفاع في تل ابيب وهناك يجري تقييم
التحركات العسكريه على الارض هذه حافله
اخرى الان تخرج من منطقه زكيم سنرى طبعا
هي مظلله هي مظلله غالبها مظلله
لا نستطيع ان نرصد بداخلها لكن واضح بانها
لم تكن تحمل جنود لكن ربما تحمل مدنيين
اذا عمليه اجلاء ربما تكون تجري الان في
بعض هذه المناطق القريبه المناطق الحدوديه
القريبه
من من قطاع غزه اذا كنا نتحدث عن المسيرات
التي ترصد وتبث ربما بصور مباشره الى غرفه
العمليات وغرفه التحكم في وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه التي تقود هذه العمليه وواضح
بان هدف هذه المسيرات رصد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه فيما اذا كانت ستحرك منصات
الصواريخ خاصه تلك بعيده المدى خاصه تلك
القادره على تسديد الضربات الى تل ابيب
والى منطقه ايلات والى بئر السبع وغيرها
من المناطق في عمق في العمق الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي من الواضح بان سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي ايضا على اهبه الاستعداد
القصوى هو يحوم في الاجواء عبر مقاتلات
تحوم في الاجواء وهي ربما تستعد لتلقي
تعليمات من قياده العمليات لتوجيه ضربات
معينه فيما اذا تم رصد اي تحرك لاطلاق
الصواريخ من اجل استهداف تحديدا المنصات
الصواريخ الصاروخيه
التي بامكانها ان تضرب العمق الاسرائيلي
ان تضرب منطقه تل ابيب والضواحي الجنوبيه
وتلك القادره على ان تضرب مدينه بئر السبع
ونتيفوت ومناطق واسعه في النقب الغربي
نشير هنا الى انه في المواجهه في عام 2021
تمكنت المقاومه الفلسطينيه من اطلاق صاروخ
بلغ مداه نحو 200 كيلومتر في العمق
الاسرائيلي هذا الصاروخ وصل الى منطقه
قريبه من مطار رامون في جنوب اسرائيل
والذي يبعد نحو 30 كيلومترا فقط عن مدينه
ايلات الواقعه على البحر الاحمر لذلك
هنالك امكانيات كبيره للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
اسرائيل تدركها وواضح بان اسرائيل تخشى في
هذه المرحله ان تنضم حركه حماس الى هذه
المواجهه وان تشارك في عمليه الرد الى
جانب الجهاد الاسلامي ذلك ان اسرائيل تعلم
بان امكانيات حركه حماس صاروخيه والعسكريه
ربما تفوق بكثير قدرات الجهات الاسلامي
الصاروخيه لذلك هي تسعى الان عبر الوسطاء
تحديدا المصريين كما يبدو
بحث او محاوله منع حركه حماس من الانضمام
الى الرد ربما المنتظر من الجانب
الفلسطيني هذا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى
هنالك ايضا رسائل كما فهمنا توجه الى قوه
اليونيفال العامله في جنوب لبنان والتي
شكلت في اعقابي انتهاء العدوان الاسرائيلي
على لبنان في عام 2006 مفاد هذه الرسائل
بان تعمل قوه اليونيفين على احباط اي رد
صاروخي من جنوب لبنان وان لا يكون تكون
الاراضي اللبنانيه مسرحا او موقعا او
منطلقا لاطلاق الصواريخ في عمليه الرد على
اسرائيل لكن الان حقيقه اسرائيل في وضع لم
تعاهده من قبل ذلك انها حتى هذه الساعه هي
لم تواجه رد الفعل الفلسطيني بالعاده كانت
تنتظر اسرائيل
ردا سريعا على عمليات الاغتيال او
العمليات العسكريه لكن نحن بعد مضي ساعات
كثيره من عمليه الاغتيال وحتى الان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لم تطلق طلقه واحده
وهذا عمليا يجعل الجيش الاسرائيلي ويجعل
الاسرائيليون هنا اسرى او ربما رهائن
لانتظار الرد الفلسطيني والرد المقاومه
واسرائيل لا تستطيع ان تنتظر كثيرا دون ان
تعرف الى اين ستتجه الامور هي من ناحيتها
تقول بان العمليه التي اطلقتها فجر هذا
اليوم حققت اهدافها وهذا يعني بانها من
ناحيه الجيش الاسرائيلي ومن ناحيه المستوى
السياسي والعسكري العمليه منتهيه حققت
اهدافها بعمليه الاغتيال وبقتل القاده
قاده الجهاد الاسلامي لكن هي الان تضع في
حسبانها بان الرد ذاته على هذه العمليه
ربما يدهور الامور الى عمليه عمليه اوسع
وعمليه ربما تستمر لايام عده هنالك حاله
ايضا بطبيعه الحال لان الرد الفلسطيني لم
ياتي والامور غير واضحه لا احد يعرف الى
اين تتجه الامور هل ستنضم حركه حماس الى
الرد هل سيقتصر الرد على الجهاد الاسلامي
هل سيكون الرد فقط في قطاع غزه ام ان
جبهات متعدده ربما تنضم الى عمليه الرد
هذا يدخل الاسرائيليين في حاله من الحيره
في حاله من الاحباط في حاله من الغضب ذلك
انهم ليسوا متعودين على هذه الاجراءات
الامنيه التي تشاهدها الان عبر الشاشه في
نصب الحواجز العسكريه ومنع الاسرائيليين
من القيام
بحياتهم الطبيعيه وهم ياتون بسياراتهم الى
هذا الموقع ويتفاجئون يعني كيف نرى في قلب
اسرائيل في شوارع اسرائيليه حواجز عسكريه
هذه مشاهد فقط للفلسطينيين الفلسطينيون هم
معتدون على مثل هذه الحواجز العسكريه لكن
هم يواجهون هذا الواقع الان وهم لا
يستطيعون ان ينتظروا كثيرا في ظل هذا
الوضع اللائق الضبابي غير المفهوم وغير
المعروف الى
يقود ولا كيف سينتهي في قادم الايام